قال تركيا انها تدعم التوصل لوقت محدود
لاطلاق النار بين روسيا واوكرانيا في غياب
اتفاق سلام شامل وشدد تنقر على انك لن
تكون قادره على استنزاف في القوه الروسيه
بالمساعدات التي تتلقاها من الغرب في
اشاره على ما يبدو الى اعلان بريطانيا
نيتها ارسال اربع 10 دبابه من طرازه
تشالنجر 2 واسلحه ثقيله الى اوكرانيا
قريبا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذلك خبر
لاطلاق النار في ظل غياب اتفاق سلام شامل
وما هي حيثيات تلك المساعيد واين وصلت
كيف نقرا اعلان لندن عزمها ارسل دبابات
الى اوكرانيا وتعقيد برلين بانها ستتابع
تعهدها بارسال دبابات قتاليه اذا قام
الحلفاء الغربيون بذلك وكيف ستنعكس هذه
الخطوه على مجريات الحرب
وما هي فرص استجابه روسيا واوكرانيا للعرض
التركي في ضوء سباق التسلح والتعبئه من
قبل الطرفين
[موسيقى]
حاد على خلفيه الموقف من الحرب الدائره
بين روسيا واوكرانيا تحتفظ تركيا بعلاقات
جيده مع كل من موسكو وكوتيات مستغله ذلك
في طرح مساعي وساطه اثمر التوافقات هشه
بشان صادرات الحبوب وتبادل اسرى الحرب
تبقى عقده المنشار هي خفض التصعيد ووقفه
الاقتتال ولا وجزئيا تمهيدا لاجواء قد
تقوده الى انهاء الحرب الى اتفاق شامل
للسلام
طريقه تعقيده الجنه
في الوقت الذي تصعده فيه روسيا هجماتها
اعلن مكتب رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سوناك اعتزاما حكومه 14 دبابه من طرازه
تشالنجر 2 واسلحه ثقيله اخرى الى اوكرانيا
خلال الاسابيع المقبله واضاف المكتب ان
لندن ستشرعه في تدريب قوه اوكرانيه على
استخدام تلك الدبابات
السفاره الروسيه لدى بريطانيا علقت على
هذه التطورات بالقول ان دبابات تشالنجر
اثنين البريطانيه لن تساعد القوات
الاوكرانيه في تغيير الوضع على الارض بل
ستصبح هدفا مشروعا للقوات الروسيه واشارت
الى ان ارسال هذه الدبابات لن يقرب من
نهايه الاعمال القتاليه بل سيسهم في
تصعيدها
[موسيقى]
بمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من انقره مراد
اصلا الخبيره الاستراتيجي والمحل السياسي
في مركز سيتا للابحاث هو من اوكسفورد
الدكتور فرانك
ليدويتش القدير العسكريه والضبط السابق في
المخابرات العسكريه البريطانيه
ونبدا معك سيد اصلا
هل من ظروف موضوعيه دفعت تركيا الى هذا
الطرح طرح الوساطه
بين اوكرانيا وروسيا في ظل احتدام المعارك
على الارض لماذا حصل ذلك اليوم
بالحقيقه
عن مسار التقليديه لفضي النزاع يكون هناك
نزاع ميداني محتدم ولكن هذا لا يعني ان
الجهود يجب ان تتوقف من اجل وقف العنف
ووقف النزاع لان كل الطرفين سوف يقيمان
الموقف من حيث المكاسب العسكريه والسياسيه
وبعد ذلك
يتخذان الموقف المناسب ما تقدمه تركيا
الان لربما لا يرتبط بشكل كبير
بمجرياته الميدان ولكنها فرصه مجددا لكل
الطرفين لكي يفكر به حلا محتمل لان النزاع
وهذا طبيعي ويجد ان يتم من قبل اي جهه
اليوم الدول الغربيه سواء كانت تحت مظله
الامم المتحده
اللي في شمال الاطلسي او الاتحاد الاوروبي
لا يهم هي هي طرف بسبب امداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه من ناحيه اخرى تركيا لديها علاقه
مع روسيا تكون تعاونيه في بعض الاحيان وفي
سياق المواجهه في احيانا الاخرى ولكن هذا
ييسر على تركيا هذا الدور يعني تركيا
نوع من الوساطه ولكن عمليا على الارض يمكن
القول ان كل الظروف غير مساعده وغير مهياه
للنجاح طرح من هذا النوع
ولد
انت على حق لان الاهداف السياسيه
والعسكريه تشير الى صوره مختلفه بشكل كامل
لذلك روسيا تود ان تحافظ على كل المحافظات
وكل المقاطعات المرتبطه بروسيا وان تكون
قد ضمت الى روسيا بعد الاستفتاء بين
مزدوجين وايضا تود روسيا ان تحافظ على
موقعها خصوصا بالقرب من نهر
وبالنسبه الى اوكرانيا يجب ان تقترب
القوات الاوكرانيه من الحدود الروسيه لكي
تقوم القوات الاوكرانيه بفصل القوات
الروسيه عن بعضها وبالتالي الظروف لم تنضج
بعد الظروف لم تنضج هنا انتقل الى الدكتور
همم
فرانك ليدويتش
بريطانيا كيف يمكن ان
تتعامل مع طرح من من هذا النوع وهي الى
جانب دول غربيه والولايات المتحده ما زالت
تغدق بالمساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا مع قناعه مسبقه على ما يبدو
بانه لن يكون هناك هزيمه كامله
لروسيا في هذه الحرب
تركيا
منصفا وعادل في هذه القضيه وانا متاكد من
ان بريطانيا والقوى الغربيه الاخرى ترى
تركيا كذلك لكن من وجهه نظر اخرى
نيه ربما مصالحهم لا تسمح لهم بان تتوقف
روسيا ولو وقفه قصيره في تجميده
القتالفهم تقدموا بشروط الصعبه لوقت اطلاق
النار ولا اتوقع من ان اي عرض تركي سلبي
مطالبهم لهذا السبب اعتقد ان الرد الروسي
الذي يكون مواطن لي الشروط الاوكرانيه
المطروح حاليا ولكن يعني في هذا المجال
يمكن القول ان الجانبين همم
اوكرانيا ايضا من للدخول في تفاوض ومن اجل
القبول
بالوسطيه تطرح شروطا عاليه السقف في مقابل
ايضا استمرار روسيا بعملياتها العسكريه
وبالتالي الجانبان مسؤولان هنا عن ضياع
فرص التفوق
تماما وانا سا ايضا اكرر اصدق شيء اخر قال
له الدكتور عصام هل ان هناك فرصه حتى في
اتفاق ووقف اطلاق النار جزئيه هذا يعني
انني يجب ان قدما في ذلك وكما سمعنا تركيا
ماضيه قدما في ذلك رغم احتدام القتال
لكنني اقول ان اكرانيا ربما لم تقبل بهذا
لان من وسط نظارهم واذا ما اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار الوضع العسكري ان اي وقت انطلاق
النار سيكون لصالح روسيا ويعطيها ميزه في
القتال
طيب سيد اصلان كان لافتا
بكلام ابراهيم قال ان القول بانه قد تظهر
فرص افضل خلال شهر او شهرين همم ربما تكون
الظروف قد مضت اكثر لماذا برايك ما الذي
يمكن ان يحصل خلال شهر او شهرين قد يدفع
باتجاه تليين المواقف اكثر
يجب ان نضغط على الزر للاتصال بالاخرين
وفي الوقت نفسه يجب ان يكون لدينا اجهزه
الاطفاء المناسبه هذا ما تخطط تركيا
للقيام به هذا اولا النقطه الثانيه لحل
هذا النزاع هناك مسار طويل كي يتفق
الطرفان ولا يزال هذا المسار ده ضاضيا في
الشهرين
المقبللين سوف يبدا الطرفان بموجات جديده
من الحملات العسكريه وسوف يقيمان ما اذا
كان باستطاعتهما ان يحققه الاهداف الوضع
الحالي في الجانب الروسي هو ان القياده
العسكريه تغيرت القياده العسكريه المشرفه
على العمليه العسكريه وهذا مؤشر بان هناك
حلقه ناقصه او كانت خاطئه في الجانب
الروسي اما اوكرانيا فهي ضعيفه
لانها تعتمد بشكل كامل على الدعم الغربي
ما ان يتوقف الدعم الغربي يجب ان تتفق مع
الرؤوس برايي في الشهرين المقبلين سوف
نعرف الى اي حد يمكن الطرفان ان يحققه
الاهداف العسكريه من خلال السبل العسكريه
وفي نهايه المطاف تتعين على الطرفين ان
يتوقفها حتى ولو اننا نتحدث عن نزاعا من
مستوى اقل فتره اطول بالحديث هنا سيد اصلا
الدعم العسكريه الغربي اوكرانيه تعزيز
المدد العسكري الغربي لصالح اوكرانيا لا
يقتصر على بريطانيا فقط همم صحيفه
نقلت ايضا عن مسؤولين المانيا قبل ان
برلين ستفي بتعهدها بارسال دبابات قتاليه
لاوكرانيا اذا انضم الحلفاء الغربيون الى
هذا المساء من جهه اعلن رئيس الوز
البولنديه ماتيوش موريتسكي انه سيجري خلال
زياره لبرلين محادثات بشان تسليم الدبابات
المانيه الصنع
نعود الى ضيفنا للوجه الدكتور
فرانكليدويتش من
اوكسفورد همم دكتور فرانك طب اذا كانت في
نهايه المطاف الدول الاوروبيه مقتنعه ان
لا انتصار حاسما لايمن الطرفين وتحديدا
لاوكرانيا هنا همم لماذا الاستمرار بالدعم
العسكري الذي كما تقول روسيا ستكون هذه
الامدادات هدفا مشروعا وستسهل في تاجيج
الصراع اذا كانت هناك
بعدم الانتصار لماذا كل هذا الدعم
والله
الى هذا الموضوع من باب الانصاف روسيا
استخدمت الصواريخ صواريخ روس صواريخ فرنسا
الدبابات ومئات الالاف من
الجنود والاف قطع المدفعيه من الصعب ان
نقول
عشره ونحو ذلك من هذا الدبابات سيؤدي الى
تصعيد طبعا هم يقولون الناس تكون هدفا
مشروعا هذا صحيح لكن لن تعتبر تصنيع
تصعيدا عفوا
الولايات المتحده في لندن بريطانيا
المانيا زود اوكرانيا
بصوارخ متوسطه
في الحقيقه يمكن ان تتسبب باضرار اكثر
بكثير من
بعض المساله فيما تعلقوا بالدبابات وليس
التصعيد لانها سوف تزيد من قوه او قدره
القوات الاوكرانيه على استعاده اراضيها
طبعا لن تكفي الدبابات لوحدها بل سيحتاجون
الى المزيد من قطع المدفعيه لهذا السبب
نرى ان هناك زياده في حجم الدعم العسكري
ان الغربي ان لم يكن من حيث النوحيه
اعتقد اننا سنرى ان الاوكرانيين
سيزداد طموحهم وعزيمتهم على استعاده
اراضيهم بسبب هذا الدعم الدكتور فرانك
بصراحه هنا اييه وهذه نقطه مهمه ذاكرها
السيد مراد اصلا انه لن يكون هناك استجابه
اوكرانيه لدعوات الحوار او التفاوض ما دام
الدعم العسكري الغربي بهذا المستوى قائم
لها متى يمكن ان يتوقف الدعم العسكري
الغربي الامريكي والاوروبي تحديدا
لاوكرانيا لدفعها نحو الذهاب الى التفاوض
اكشن اكشن
تماما في طرح هذه النقطه نحن نرى مؤشرات
وحتى في المملكه المتحده اليوم سمعنا من
رئيس لجنه الدفاعيه المنبثقه عن البرلمان
بان
اننا او بريطانيا يجب ان نبحث في مساله هل
يرد على سؤالك بشكل مباشر وهي مساله
استعاده القمم اعتقد الناس تلك النقطه
ستشهد ان لم يكن وقفا
لدعم لكن بحث
هل معرفه
اعتقد ان هناك فخ في الكرم لا اعتقد ان لا
المتحده ستقبل بدخول اوكرانيا الى شبه
جزيره العرب
لكن الان نحن في مرحله همم ان روسيا تتقدم
في شرق اوكرانيا وهي همم ضمت اربع مقاطعات
هناك يعني وكانك تجزم بانه اوكرانيا قادره
على استعاده هذه المقاطعات ولم يبقى ولم
يبقى الا القرن اساسا هل الطرح واقعي بعد
كل هذه المتغيرات العسكريه باختصار ارجوك
سيد لدويتش
كمان
قال اعتقد كان ذلك كان في سبتمبر الماضي
ومؤخرا اكد ذلك ان الهدف الرئيس للقوات
الاوكرانيه هذا العام سيكون شبه جزيره
الكرم والذي سماها هو مركز ثقل الجاذبيه
او او بعباره اخرى هو نقطه الضعف في
المجهود الحربي الروسي وهذا ما اعلنته
اقرانه المشكله السياسيه في اوكرانيا ان
الرئيس ذا لاسكي قرر المره تلو الاخرى بان
اهداف الحرب الاوكرانيه تتضمن القيم هذا
طبعا سيكون مشكله اذا ما كان هناك تفاوض
او توقفت القوات الاخرى دون تحقيق ذلك
هذا سيشكل مشكله خاصه اذا قال الغرب هذه
النقطه يجب ان تتوقفوا عندها ولا تبدا
مرحله الدخول الى القبر ربما اوكرانيا لن
تصل الى ذلك لكن هذا هو هدفهم على ما يبدو
هذا العام همم لنصل همم الى الى باقي
المناطق قبل الحديث عن القرم هنا سيد همم
تركيا ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه في هذا
الاطار انطلاقا من علاقتها ايضا الجيده مع
مع روسيا هل لديها خريطه طريق همم واضحه
في هذا المجال يعني نحن امام همم طروحات
متباعده كليا ومتناقضه بينما يطلبه
الاوكرانيون وما همم يصل اليه الروس اذا
وصلوا في تنازلاتهم
ضرر النظف حقيقي
الى حل نزاع مماثل لا نتحدث فقط عن روسيا
واوكرانيا لا نتحدث فقط عن توقعات تركيا
او ما تقترحه تركيا في هذا السياق بل
الامر يتخطى ذلك هناك ديما ديناميه متعدده
على سبيل المثال اذا ما كان الهدف السياسي
لروسيا هو ان تكون النتيجه مختلفه في
اوكرانيا عما هي عليه اليوم الناس على
سبيل المثال يتناقشون
بامكانيه هجوم مع بيلاروسيا من الشمال هذا
سوف يغير المعطيات بشكل كامل ثانيا هناك
دائما مناقشات حول استخدام
السلاح النوويه التكتيكيه من قبل الروس
ولكن ما ان يستخدم هذا السلاح الوضع يختلف
اذا حتى الافعال والتصرفات في الميدان
تؤطر عمليه فض النزاع بن الى الموقف
التركي الاجنده تقضي بالبدء بوقفا جزئيا
لاطلاق النار وصولا الى الوقف الدائم
لاطلاق النار وبعد ذلك ينتقل الطرفان
للتفاوض لان النزاع لديه دائما سبب وايضا
عمليه السياسيه يجب ان تبدا من نقطه محدده
هناك ايضا نقطه مهمه اذا ما كان لدى اي من
الطرفين امل بتحقيق النصر اعتقدوا انه
يتعاون علينا ان ننتظر حتى يفقد الطرف هذا
الامل هذا ما شاهدناه حتى الان اوكرانيا
لديها امل وبوتن كذلك هذا يعني انه يتعين
علينا ان ننتظر حتى يندثر الامل ولكن همم
كيف يعني كيف يمكن ان يقتنع طرف من
الطرفين بانه لن يستطيع ان ينتصر
نحن نتحدث هنا عن القدرات
اذا ما شعر اي طرف بانه قادر لا نتوقع منه
ان يخطوا باتجاه الحلول الدبلوماسيه
والسياسيه وهذا ما نشاهده اليوم القرن على
سبيل المثال هي مكان تصر فيه روسيا على
الحفاظ عليه على الحفاظ على شبه جزيره
القرم وكانه ارض روسيه ولكن لا اتوقع ان
تقبل اوكرانيا بتقديم هذا التنازل
وبالتالي يجب او لدينا فكره حول كيفيه
اطلاق المسار السياسي ولكن لسوء الحظ
الظروف لم تنضج بعض ولكن يتعين علينا ان
نجهز على الاقل اللي هي العمليه
المستقبليه من انقره مراد اصلا الخبير
الاستراتيجي والمحل السياسي في مركز سته
للابحاث شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا للدكتور
فرانك ليد ويتش من اوت سبورت القبيل
العسكري والضابط السابق في المخابرات
العسكريه
البريطاني
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]